It is impossible for a Disney film to be released
without garnering attention, whether it be
from the massive ticket sales, the indelible
mark on pop culture, or the continued dedication
by children and adults who become entranced
by the characters and music featured in the
films.
Even with Disney’s most beloved films, controversy
often looms.
Here are 10 Famous Disney Movies that Caused
Serious Controversy.
Zootopia
Zootopia is the 2016 film that endeared itself
to children and adults with its lovable characters
and its meaningful tale of two unlikely animals
solving a case, forging a friendship, and
reaching for what they want despite their
limitations.
Judy Hopps is the bunny with the determination
to become a police officer for the big city
of Zootopia.
Zootopia raised controversy for its attempts
to speak about sexism, racism and the war
on drugs through the lens of a family friendly
film.
Judy is considered weak, the predator animals
considered violent and prone to crime, and
the growing of plants that only aggravate
an aggressive response, are all included in
Zootopia.
While some critics and viewers found the film
desperate to comment on too many societal
issues, the box-office persevered.
Mulan
1998’s Mulan follows the story of real life
Chinese legend, Hua Mulan.
Mulan is a young woman who disguises herself
as a man to take the place of her father in
battle.
Some critics found the gender roles to be
troubling but the primary controversy revolved
around the way Asian culture was portrayed.
Some of the Asian stereotypes depicted in
the film bothered viewers especially once
it was released in China.
Most recently a new controversy over the upcoming
live action version of Mulan has sprouted.
An online petition has been conceived asking
Disney to not “whitewash” the character
by casting a white actress when there are
so many underrepresented minority actors who
would be better suited for the role.
101 Dalmatians
In 1996 Disney gave their 1961 classic film,
101 Dalmatians a live action update.
It was a much different time with a whole
new set of expectations and controversy that
came along with it.
While animal rights groups were troubled with
the dog snatching Cruella De Vil, most were
already familiar with her villainous motivations
in the decades since the original film’s
release.
The real problem came from the audience's
perception of the adorable Dalmatian puppies
featured in the film.
After the release, Dalmatian puppies became
the must-have Christmas gift for children.
However, the new dog owners failed to realize
that those pups grow to be much bigger and
the breed of Dalmatians may not have the most
ideal temperament for small children.
The Humane Society was overwhelmed with the
breed months after the release of the film.
It became even more of an issue when the animated
series debuted not long after.
Alice in Wonderland
The 1951 animated film, Alice in Wonderland,
based on Lewis Carroll’s Alice Books, is
one of the most surreal films and features
many instances of drug use by most of the
characters in the film.
While there wasn’t much discussion of Alice’s
use of Mushrooms, Caterpillars constant Hookah
usage, or the trippy images in the film after
its initial release, controversy arose in
the late 60s when drug culture became common.
After 1968’s Yellow Submarine was released,
there was a surge of interest in Alice in
Wonderland as it was considered ahead of its
time.
Parents to an entire new generation of Wonderland
watchers became concerned that the loopy imagery
and prevalent drug suggestions throughout
the film were harmful to young viewers.
Toy Story 2
Sometimes there are controversies that arise
within the confines of Disney studios but
through the power of the internet, become
public.
This was the case with Toy Story 2.
After the success of the first film, Disney
and Pixar began working on a sequel.
The film was expected to be a straight-to-video
but when executives were impressed with the
footage, they pushed for a theatrical release.
The animators were not fond of the footage
that had been completed causing tension between
the creatives and executives.
Things became even more complicated when a
Pixar employee accidentally erased the Toy
Story data.
Millions of dollars and years of work deleted
in a moment.
What the studio didn’t know was that the
film’s supervising technical director had
a copy with her as she had recently had a
baby and was working from home.
With the relief of the saved footage, the
continued arguments between the suits and
animators dissipated.
Tangled
In the 20th century Disney films have been
filled with Princesses who need the help of
a Prince to save them from whatever or whomever
they need to be saved from.
Ariel only desired to walk among the humans
in exchange for her voice, Snow White tended
to seven small strangers until she was poisoned
and had to be revived by the kiss of a prince.
The list goes on.
The 21st century appeared to be making strides
toward feminism.
2010’s Tangled was expected to turn things
around but Disney still managed to miss the
mark.
Female and Male viewers alike were dumbfounded
by the perpetuation of the patriarchy as Rapunzel
still needed to be saved by the male lead,
Flynn Rider.
He wasn’t a prince but just a capable man
who seemed to be the only one who could save
the damsel in distress from her castle.
Even with the question of gender roles, many
observers noted that Tangled was at least
a step in the right direction.
Pocahontas
Disney has a history of using existing material
and giving it a lighthearted makeover that
will appeal to a mass audience.
1995’s Pocahontas is a film guilty of taking
a real person and completely overhauling her
story.
In the film, Pocahontas is shown as a young
Native American woman who saves and then falls
in love with Colonist John Smith, but in real
life she was only a ten year-old child when
Smith arrived and there was no romance between
the two.
The real Pocahontas was abducted by colonists
not long after and married off to a tobacco
magnate.
Disney dismissing the actual events of her
life disappointed and angered historians who
found the film to be a way to tie a family-friendly
and romantic bow on historical events that
did not end with a happily ever after.
Finding Dory
Finding Dory, the sequel to 2003’s massively
successful Finding Nemo, was another hit for
Disney with the story centering on the forgetful
fish who goes on her own adventure.
Prior to the film’s release, there was buzz
that a same-sex couple would make an appearance,
a first for Disney.
There was controversy with the appearance
alone, but once the film was released, there
was another reason the film raised a few eyebrows.
The so-called same sex couples characters
were simply a brief moment in which two women
who may or may not be a couple, make a blink-and-you’ll
miss-it appearance.
The Controversy of Finding Dory came from
two opposing groups concerning the same issue
but with Disney’s lack of committing to
either side, ended up angering both.
Aladdin
1992’s Aladdin has provided a wealth of
controversy due to its Arabian stereotypes
and the questionable skin color and features
of its two leads.
The controversy that concluded with Disney
making an alteration is the song “Arabian
Nights”.
The original release of film included the
lyrics “Where they cut off your ear if they
don’t like your face”.
The American-Arab anti-Defamation league rightly
took issue with this offensive line resulting
in Disney changing it for the home video release.
While the lyrics were changed to “Where
it’s flat and immense and the heat is intense”
a scene in which Jasmine nearly gets her hand
chopped off for stealing an apple and the
line “It’s barbaric, but, hey, it’s
home” remain in the film.
Moana
Disney is known for raking in money from not
only movie tickets but from the merchandise
inspired by their popular movies.
Even before a film’s release, fans are able
to purchase items at the company’s store
and other retailers.
The upcoming film Moana, about a teenage girl
who goes on a daring adventure to save her
people, is the subject of Disney’s most
recent controversy for a Halloween costume
based on the character Maui.
The costume features a brown bodysuit adorned
with Polynesian tattoos to better resemble
the character who is a Polynesian Demigod,
This angered many on social media, calling
it cultural appropriation.
Disney was quick to react to the complaints
and immediately removed the costume from the
stores.
While issues of race insensitivity are not
new for the house of mouse, it is less common
in recent years and the company has used social
media as a way to fix their missteps.
There’s our list.
What do you think?
What Disney controversies did we forget?
Let us know in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe to our channel.